in croatia is uh a bit terrible now so
if if there's gonna be a storm or
something my internet could like go down
instantly
yeah we've had also issues uh it's also
really really stormy so
yeah yeah hopefully it doesn't but we'll
see
all right it seems like uh it seems like
it's working and uh
let me just check okay everything here
is
is working nicely the chat is uh the
chat is already
uh fully operational
uh so hello everyone uh the tournament
is already starting in one minute and 30
seconds uh we're gonna enjoy some
wonderful games and uh
uh we're gonna uh talk about a lot of
stuff i have here the ceo of cake defy
julian hospier so hello julian
hey such a honor and pleasure to be on
normally i always watch your videos and
uh yeah and learn as much about chess
here um yeah it's nice to be on the
other side
martin schmidt asks does cake defy make
cakes
i know martin he's just uh uh yeah he's
just uh joking
no we are a crypto company so for anyone
that doesn't know we are a crypto
company that provides cash flow on
cryptocurrencies uh actually funny story
on the name um the name came up because
uh yeah it's about like get a slice of
the cake um but the very interesting one
is in singapore uh the company name
cake no one has taken ever
so yeah that was the actual fun kind of
note how the name cake came about
uh you you also have to have like a
unique name
yeah you register a company name and and
cake was available which was really uh
interesting considering that no one in
singapore has ever taken the company
name cake
yeah website and everything is gone but
the company in singapore was not taken
so that was interesting
yeah i was uh when i was starting my
company i tried to open up like an uh
agatmator.com and not come but uh
in crash it's like doo and uh they asked
me if i was sure that it if it if it
wasn't taken and i'm uh yeah i'm pretty
sure but
in croatia at the time you didn't have
to have like uh it
wasn't have to be like for the entire
country but only for your city
like there could there could be
many of them you know in different
cities but now i think they covered that
now i think there can be only one for
for the entire one all right so the
tournament has started
yeah let me just uh open this up
uh and let's check it all right so
usually we start with a game from our
leader uh but
for the moment his game hasn't started
so we're gonna start with this one
let's see if that is now all right so
it's fully operational
all right do you have the do you have
the games yep
all right there we go
that should be a really oh wow okay
someone is uh interesting
yeah
i let you the uh like i think you're way
better than me on the chest analysis
because my elo is actually
about 2 000 so i definitely cannot
um
uh oh someone said i disappeared no no
you're here i'm just tricking them into
thinking you disappeared
nana you're here no worries
yeah okay so we're not going be uh
analyzing all that much this is pretty
much bullet so this is uh you know uh
only for fun we're gonna wait uh i'm
gonna be covering uh uh uh
showing the games as they're being
played uh but uh you know after like the
first 50 moves have been played then
we'll we will do some commenting and uh
first uh
maybe like in in half an hour but we
will always be covering uh at least uh
some of the games from the top ten and
then of course we're gonna check out the
other games as well uh since uh we're
not only going to
be showing the games from the leaders uh
this is two plus also
every game is pretty wild
what uh what format do you enjoy playing
uh i cannot i'm not that fast of a
player uh for me five plus zero is
already
like my my uh
yeah the limit i think like i i
deteriorate as soon as i play like three
plus two or something or three plus zero
i deteriorate so much um i i just can't
uh i'm not that fast so for me the five
plus zero or or ten plus zero these are
the time limits that for me are very
comfortable
right i mean of course right there like
i can think a bit i can actually
uh
yeah
yeah what about for yourself
i mostly play bullet and hyper bullet
but
lately i've tried to squeeze in some
three pluso blitz anything above that is
uh
it takes up too much time i don't know
but uh okay uh i i've been mostly
focusing on bullet hyper bullet i
haven't played for like a year
and now that i've uh
i tried to go back to it but it's so so
damn fast so i probably shouldn't have
stopped playing it because i was always
like a hundred rating points higher
rated on hyper bullet than on bullet but
now it's the the other way around
uh so maybe maybe i'm just getting older
who knows maybe
maybe also that has something to do with
it i i was always wondering how do you
actually analyze those games from
from
like
i mean obviously you talk a lot about
how people recommend games to you and
then you look at the game how do you
then go about it i would be interested
how long does it take you to to analyze
one of those games and then uh the other
thing that really makes me super curious
how do you actually show the game on
your screen that that you have all the
arrows drawn and all the things going
like how do you do that i was always
curious how does like how how how do you
do that in an effect does this take you
hours or or how long does that take uh
depends on the game really uh
you don't have to really worry about the
arrows or anything the interface does
that by itself you can just draw them uh
like this okay now you disappeared again
uh as i can't really lock the the zoom
meeting or at least i think i can't uh
on the screen
uh but um
uh
that's that's the easy part the hard
part is you have to analyze the moves
obviously the the games are played by
extremely strong grandmasters so you
have to be very careful about what
you're saying
and it takes uh it takes a reasonable
amount of time
uh of course you have to check all the
you know tricky lines with the engine
okay not the openings but then if
something gets really complicated then
you have to
let the engine crunch the numbers then
the engine is like depth 15 depth 16
depth 17 and then depending on how much
time you have you let it crunch the
numbers as much as possible uh to make
it not only interesting for your
audience but also uh
you know sometimes if you would just
check the engine
up to maybe uh
evaluation level of uh depth 15 then it
would probably be a mistake most of the
time
and if you let it crunch the numbers up
until depth 35 or maybe 40
that's uh well that's more more
incredible
for my usual videos i don't really do
that that much depth i
don't go above 30 but if it's like a
really important game of world chess
championship game or something like that
then even depth 50 or higher as uh well
every super super computer in the world
is pretty much analyzing those games and
uh we have
a lot more resources
[Music]
and and then how do you make sure that
all the like that you remember what the
players played and what happens next
because to me like whenever you watch
the video obviously it seems you're
recording this in pretty much one go um
and and yeah but then how do you make
sure that you know which move happens
next what are all the variations what
would be an another option how do you go
about that you have like little notes on
the side or how do you do that yeah you
have little notes on the side but also
after you analyze the game and you you
know go through it for like half an hour
then you already know what was played
and uh it's not really i mean you have
to
uh see all the critical moves the
critical position the
what was missed what wasn't missed and
then okay you have the little notes but
even if you did it you'd remember the
game without much problems
all right let me just check another one
from the leaders that just started that
was a pretty ugly one here more sinkhead
no chance yeah we have fide master
rwanda versus lucas george 2000.
all right
you you disappear from time to time but
that's uh totally normal
uh maybe there's a oh yeah there's
actually an option keep on top wow i
don't know if that's like a zoom option
or is that like uh you know operating
system but
you're not gonna be disappearing anymore
and i don't know what is this uh story
about you always uh bending down and
saying oh sorry about that and then
actually i don't know nothing ever
happens but
what is that
uh
i've actually explained it a few times
but it's uh when i i forget to lower the
sound of my speakers before i uh start
showing the game and then i make a move
and then the
sound is heard on the
on the speakers but also the microphone
picks it up so it's a double sound and
there's a little delay between the two
sounds so it's instead of a click it's a
click
you know it's not easy to pick up but
people hear it i mean if
those who use headphones
i have not heard about that uh in the
video so obviously i missed it at some
point
yeah i mean i could obviously restart
and then you know just like it's fine
i always thought it was like some
insider that you did yeah like very
early in your youtube career and then uh
it just kind of
uh kept going on and i don't know uh
yeah so like what is that actually
yeah but it's uh when i was just
starting out with the channel i was
still having my day job and that took a
lot of time i also had a second job
which was you know editing weddings and
you know shooting weddings over the
weekends
so doing chess videos uh couldn't really
take all that much of my time and that's
why i pretty much never edited out any
mistakes i just
did it in one go and now i i could
afford maybe the time okay not with the
baby not so much but
uh i still prefer to do it in one go and
you know
what happens happens all right we can
change the game without you uh
disappearing
all right we have a we have i think the
chat says sorry about that sorry about
that yeah it is
it is hilarious yeah yeah we have one
grand master in the
in the tournament it's his name is cake
in space
i have no idea who that is uh let me
just change the name let me just check
quickly no he's anonymous
i think yeah he's an or maybe someone
knows who cake in space is but uh it
doesn't say honestly just changed the
name to that
yeah and he and the leader now the
leader the
top seed of the tournament uh mate
from russia have already played quite a
lot of games
and cake in space is leading with eleven
and a half to seven and a half so
should be should be very interesting i
think uh we have our two top contenders
uh already in this one
i probably hikaru rob v says no i don't
think it's hikaru hikaru is only allowed
to move you know in the domain of of
chess.com
oh really is that so uh i believe so i
mean it was uh at at some point i don't
know if that changed but uh like i'm
pretty sure it is
like
obviously he can play anonymously but i
don't think uh i don't think he can play
publicly on other platforms
interesting i didn't know that
yeah
in your entire youtube career so like i
have a youtube channel mine is about 200
000 people and i uh talk about bitcoin
and it's obviously german um
and and i remember there was this one
video in 2017 that
like got me from 6 000 subscribers to
like a hundred thousand subscribers
yeah there was like one video and uh it
was it was talking about the bitcoin
half thing in 2017. was there like this
breakthrough point for you as well where
suddenly you were like you know from one
day to another there was this one video
that just made my channel like blow up
yeah okay yeah but not in that uh
spectrum uh uh it was uh when i first
bought this microphone the the blue yeti
or rather my girlfriend got it
for my birthday maybe
six years ago
and i did my first video with this new
microphone it was a video about the
bobby fischer game uh how he crushed his
opponent and then his opponent resigned
like in 12 moves but it was a total
fiasco because that's not actually true
the game lasted for 40 moves and i
didn't know that i just uh i was pretty
nah i was uh
i was pretty sure i had the
the moves uh correct in my head and then
i just you know
didn't check before
uh recording and that video got like a
couple of million views and it
it propelled the channel a little bit
but not uh quite like that like i got
maybe i was at maybe
3 000 subscribers at that point and then
it jumped to maybe five or something
like that
so no nothing drastic like wait yeah but
you cannot tell me that like from your
like all the way to like what are you
now 1.2 uh yeah 1.2 million yeah was
there no point where suddenly it was
like
like yeah it just
it just went hyperbolic no no just
completely gradual
wow
like yeah that that is weird not because
most people just uh you know do go like
that they they get to that one video
that propels them
uh but i i've actually uh spent a lot of
time just uh
making videos without them getting any
views uh and then like
that first video where i got this
microphone that was the one that kind of
started attracting more and more people
i don't know if it was the first video
that i made about bobby fischer maybe
also that had something to do with it
but uh could be could be anything really
are there certain types of videos that
where you know if i make those uh like a
lot of people gonna watch like for me if
i make a video so i saw this in the chat
before where someone said thanks so much
for your cryptography course like i made
this 20 part series about cryptography
right it's like a college level course
super a lot of work i mean almost no one
watches it right even though it's like
fundamental and then i mean if i made a
video on uh what's the price of bitcoin
going to be by the end of the year
everyone would watch that right so yeah
like do you know the same thing for
yourself as well we're like if i make
that kind of video um i know a lot of
people are gonna watch uh like
magnus like
obviously for me like magnus playing
hikaru playing like that always triggers
me at least uh the videos but definitely
i'm gonna watch uh yeah magnus playing
uh definitely will uh
grant you more views but not uh not by
all that much
but other than that regardless of what i
make like it gets pretty much the same
amount of views
so
like maybe if you did something
different if you make because like i
always feel um obviously that it because
it's a really nice way to update when
you talk about like tournaments going on
uh for me it's like a super easy way to
like stay up to date with that do you
feel that those kind of videos get get
you more views or do you feel it's more
like if you actually do chess basics or
openings or mid game strategies and game
strategies like or uh or really that is
totally doesn't matter
uh well i stopped really worrying about
that i i don't
to me now it doesn't really make all
that much of a difference if i get like
a hundred thousand views per day two
hundred thousand three hundred thousand
of course everyone wants to get more
views
but if you try to really just you know
focus on that you're gonna
you're gonna be losing on quality and
you're gonna be losing on a lot because
uh i don't know i was doing the morphe
saga for like a year and a half and uh
those videos uh okay don't get you as
many views as as a magnus or a hikaru
video would but it was it's something
that i do on this channel and i'm
preparing the next saga yeah and uh
i mean okay maybe if you if this is like
a really serious business for you and
you're from a
wealthy country but uh
maybe you know you have to take such
things into consideration but me i'm
from croatia you know even
even
uh
if i was making like much much less from
youtube but still be doing the the exact
same thing so for me it's not an issue
for some someone it might be
sure
no i i think that's great yeah um makes
a i mean i i told you up front i'm yeah
i've been
i have these faces where i don't like
sometimes i get too much addicted to
chest and i have to take a pause and
it's like a couple of months when i
really have to kind of get up take a
pause and then there's these times where
i'm just like literally watching every
single video you put out uh yeah stay up
to date learn um
yeah i yeah uh play a little bit myself
um yeah so it's uh
do you have a do you have like like a
favorite uh player yourself
yeah i mean i don't know i i always uh
i'm not too much of the underdog person
so i love to route for the champion so
for me i'm definitely a
a a madness fan uh i hope he wins the
the championship in dubai next month so
um you're not rooting for
uh mid-november
you're not rooting for nipple not even a
little bit
no no i'm really i'm like i'm i'm i'm
totally uh uh the champion like yeah i
don't know i'm not so much of an uh
maybe also because i have like whenever
i i was a professional kite surfer and i
was
always
like very very good in in doing so and
um sorry professional kiters
yeah kite surfing yeah like you flew a
kite so
yeah it's like a mix between surfing and
a kite and you like surf on the water
and
uh yeah you can
uh
yeah i don't know just uh look uh
i don't know just type in the the term
kitesurf um
yeah uh and i i was a professional for
10 years and uh and i don't know and i
was always very good so for me um i
don't know i i never
like like to root for the for the
underdog or for the con like for the
challenger um
yeah i don't know
okay i don't know i support the champion
but uh although okay magnus winning of
course is what uh i believe like maybe
60 or 70 percent people are hoping for
as that's you know pretty normal but
what people don't understand that if
magnus loses uh then uh magnus goes
straight into the candidates tournament
in the next cycle and then we have
another candidates tournament where
magnus is playing
now that is something that that that
could be very enjoyable how will he play
the the tournament that he absolutely
must win
yeah and
you know
i also hope so i i don't i don't like as
a spectator i wouldn't want magnus to
totally destroy nepo right i think that
would be boring but uh i think it would
be awesome to have some
like
yeah for me it would be great to have
some close games obviously an apple
winning one just to like because
obviously from a spectator standpoint it
just makes it super exciting um yeah
yeah maybe
like like in the last cycle uh we'll get
also some some rapid games if the
classical games end in a draw yep
yeah that would be very curious yeah
yeah and uh i i can't even imagine what
what openings will be played i mean
every every time it's such a
you know
you think okay of course it's gonna be
the berlin and it's going to be
some nasty you know slav or something
but uh then you know it totally
surprises you fabi brought out the the
petrov defense you know and anything
could happen i believe especially with
nepo
and i i don't know if uh we know
i don't know if we know who carlson's
seconds are because he always keeps them
a secret uh so
we'll see what he what he prepared for
this one
like uh
in prior worlds championship cycles it
was sort of a custom to announce who
your seconds were uh but magnus always
for some reason keeps it a secret uh
is it uh why does he do that is that
just
i don't know
maybe be
or maybe to be more mysterious or maybe
to psych out his opponent or maybe
i'm sure he has a reason maybe he will
reveal it at some point
all right but black is really you know
uh creating down in the position here
huh yeah creating a masterpiece
yeah
wow yeah
one pin after the other
yeah wherever the king goes is just the
massacre
that was that was a good one by by papa
papa attack or pap attack
nicely done all right so we're 20
minutes into the tournament uh the
leader is currently zikla
uh i don't think uh if we know who that
person is nope it's a it's an anonymous
player with zero tournament points and
okay he does have some games so we're
gonna have to
uh check after the tournament but uh
cake in space also without a single loss
or under in third place uh assenio he
also joins the tournaments uh you know
from time to time uh gordness city
algorithm uh maleki kiras vibhav fgh
9050 and anonymous uh from india
so we'll see what happens i've seen
ronaldinho my brother-in-law he was in
the top 10 a few seconds ago but now he
dropped somewhere to 25 yeah it's it's a
tough tournament
uh all right but let's see one but
what's his elo what what's your
brother-in-law's ilo
uh elo is like um 2000 but uh he doesn't
play uh uh you know in tournaments that
again ilo he mostly plays unleashes and
in like in
blitz or bullet he gets up to 2400
wow
yeah but it's uh you know it's it's on a
good day then on a bad day he drops back
to maybe 22.50 and then you know
it repeats all over again
like i i sometimes think that i do much
much better if i play in the morning
it's sort of like i
the opponents are
maybe uh
easier or maybe i i prefer opponents
from different time zones i don't know
and then i log in in the evening and
then like everyone is playing
brilliantly
or maybe i just uh
maybe i just i i have to wake up early
maybe it's maybe i'm tired in the
evenings but i don't know
i always what was this
whoa
stuff is they're pre-moving so fast that
stuff is disappearing
this is pretty crazy
why is
uh are you are you seeing this
yeah i also saw that suddenly the pawns
disappeared yeah something is something
is very odd here
all right
yeah c and d pawns totally disappeared
yeah black is offering a draw for some
reason and he's up a queen
because he's low on time
seriously
white declines a draw
what
what what is this madness what what are
they maybe that queen is an i don't know
maybe that queen doesn't exist it sounds
like the queen doesn't exist
oh we see a queen that doesn't exist wow
yeah that's uh that's a good point yeah
that makes sense oh and now of course
black will just try to flag him
okay this does not happen very often
maybe they should put
one of the pieces on the d8 square and
see what happens
i'm pretty sure the players don't see it
it's maybe just a glitch
for the viewers yeah it's a ghost queen
kasparov talked about a ghost queen uh
during his match with the deep blue so
this is the
ghost queen second sighting
yeah that queen doesn't exist
okay now the rook fell all right wow
they're gonna play like a million moves
and sikla wins
that is just that is just brutal
oh no tikla lost oh that's the first
loss
for some reason
huh okay i have no idea what just
happened
all right let's uh kick in space still
with uh with a perfect score uh future
world chess champion from norway all
right let's check out his game against
mr green lantern o7
so you're you're still in germany
i am
what's the uh
back in uh singapore on the weekend
what's the
flight from germany to singapore is it
like a one-way ticket or
yeah no no it's a round trip uh came
here for a super short time saw the
family flying back
um
yeah back on on sunday again
how long is the trip it's like 13 hours
13 hours yeah
yeah that's that's not bad insane long
time
how's the how's the internet in germany
ah man they have couple wires here it's
so slow that's why i've been having
issues the entire week with the internet
right now it's actually quite good uh
but other than that sometimes it's just
a nightmare uh it's incredible how a
country like that is so bad with the
internet seriously yeah we have copper
wires here as well i mean i i still
don't have optic internet
yeah in singapore i have uh 1000 mbit
it's insane uh the internet is so fast
yeah
that's uh that sounds unfair that really
sounds unfair that's like a gigabit
connection
yeah it is and that's the slowest one
you can get like you cannot even get
anything slower than a bit it's crazy
yeah i've seen someone on twitter i
think from finland posted like he has a
1.2 gigabit uh connection and i'm like
that's just not fair on on a good day i
have 50 megabits uh if if it's raining
or if the wind is blowing it goes down
to 10
so you know i i'd upload my videos much
faster but it's you know
it doesn't really work
but yeah singapore
doing well
on the internet side of things huh
yeah yeah i mean they're super
futuristic when it comes to that so yeah
yeah how long have you how long have you
been in in in crypto
uh
well i had to get into it a little bit
since people started making requests to
make uh donations to the channel in
crypto around 2016
uh i think around that yeah
uh but i didn't really started you know
learning anything or really knew
anything about it until maybe 2019.
got it so like uh i i i
it was one summer i i thought all right
now i'm at the beach i'm gonna you know
grab my kindle and i grabbed a couple of
books you know on crypto and i you know
enjoyed the the beach read some books
and uh
then i've learned some things uh so now
like now i know at least a little bit
ah interesting okay that's how it comes
with the time here
yeah yeah i was uh right right after the
the big crash so to say
yeah
yeah
yeah let's see where we're going right
now
uh prices are all term high so may also
be skipped at the moment
why risky
uh i think uh we could see some
volatility um to the down and to the up
um so i think at the moment it's just
like
people who are
balls deep into crypto
i would just be a bit more cautious
let's say it this way i think if you are
a lot of people are really like yoloing
in there so
uh now
uh let's get rich quick i think that's a
bit of a
ah at the moment maybe a bit of a
dangerous approach
um yeah i think we're gonna see good
prices this year but yeah i
i don't know i would just be a bit more
cautious um with the volatility right
now i i think it it could be a bit
tricky yeah okay but uh if you're
properly like into crypto you you i mean
you kind of have to look at the big
picture you can't just uh
go for from month to month i mean it's
uh like you should look at that then
you're apparently how most people are i
mean you know how most people are most
people don't see it this way right most
people see it like okay i put in 100
right now i want to have a thousand
dollars next week and if they don't have
that they start going crazy so
yeah yeah it's uh uh it's hard i mean
when you first start and then you know
you invest something and you it just you
know stays there or it keeps going down
uh
it uh really
uh tends to
you know
improve your nerves uh to some level
but maybe it doesn't have that effect on
everyone you know sometimes maybe it uh
it has has a negative effect on people
uh but if i don't know i i don't uh i
don't try to look at it that way at all
i'm just like okay if you if you're into
bitcoin or something one bitcoin is
worth one bitcoin and that's it i mean
uh
if you're not in it for the for for the
quick buck or anything if you're in it
for for that then one bitcoin is one
bitcoin and that's it
but of course everyone is everyone is
very happy when if the pumps see it that
way yeah
yeah and then you
it helps when you don't have the
struggle financially of course but uh
yeah i think it's uh you have to look at
it that way for for everything in life
that's a really good mindset uh just
many many people don't see it this way
yeah
it's yeah
what you've been how long in crypto
you're like uh like a pioneer
yeah i'm not a pioneer right it's just
seven years now uh since 2014
uh long time i mean um and my first
bitcoin i bought at 400
sure there's people who bought them way
cheaper um
yeah but this is super cheap compared to
today uh i bought my first uh ease at
eight dollars right it's man it's just
yeah uh we're talking about like
so much price difference to the day as
crm today is at 4 000. so did someone
talk you into it or
uh i was a medical doctor before um and
then i had a patient in 2011 who told me
about bitcoin and he like i i thought
this guy was totally crazy um and that
was in 2011 and then yeah in 2014 i
stumbled across it again and then i got
super courageous because like wow three
years ago this thing is still around and
then i got really interested and i was
in hong kong back then then i actually
met vitalik buterin in hong kong it's
about six years ago he's the co-founder
of ethereum and then moved to singapore
then it was just a really vibrant
ecosystem uh yeah so
uh yeah we started cake defy in 2019
with my business partners in singaporean
um yeah i mean as a company we're doing
really well we
provide cash flow from cryptocurrencies
we have now 80 employees
uh yeah 200 000 customers it's man it's
it's just a super vibrant space right
and enough
over time you just get to learn a lot so
yeah it's a crazy crazy uh ecosystem
really
but where uh how do you how do you came
up with the idea or rather just you know
the name cake and the the idea of such
thing was there a need in the world that
needed to be filled or
what's the what's the difference like
with
till that point i think especially until
that point um 2018 when the market
really crashed everything in crypto was
about
buying and selling was
everything was about trading and uh
using my business partner and i
we had made a lot a lot of money from
from from crypto and
and at the end it's it's just like in
real estate it's one thing to just have
a property somewhere it's another thing
to get rental income so we thought hey
we need to build a platform that like
where we could actually invest our funds
and where other people can invest their
funds that just uses various streams to
generate cash flow and that's how in
2019 cake started to
to form uh yusun was the one who came up
with the name he was the one who said oh
it's a piece of cake and then he
realized uh the company name was still
available um yeah and then it started
growing and and now it's all about
lending and staking and liquidity mining
and uh we're adding this quarter is
going to be super exciting we're going
to be adding stocks and precious metals
um but in a tokenized form so that's
really really innovative um yeah so
that's just how everything grew and
so you don't have to carry your bags of
gold wherever you go
[Laughter]
oh
there was a nice queen sacrifice getting
ready but the white spotted it
ah man
uh but yeah uh
uh one thing i i wanted to ask you uh
okay you have many many things on your
on your platform that are available like
staking like landing like uh obviously a
lot of a lot of things that many other
people are offering uh but you have much
much better conditions how do you how do
you
successfully do this
like you have the yeah not on all i mean
not on all we sometimes get criticized
that uh that this rate or or that uh
offer like it's so much better on this
other platform so i think on some we
have better deals on on others we don't
um we try to offer really good rates um
one thing i think like to be super
transparent which is important in the
crypto space because there's so many
scams um and and then we try to be super
easy to use and i think at the end
that's what we do really well actually
uh both of those things uh yeah and
so yeah and again some companies do
better and one thing we we really try to
to do well on as many um yeah we don't
always manage uh just like any company
you try your best sometimes you fall
short
what's uh what's required to start a
company like cake d5 for example
ah just one person that uh actually just
takes one person who says you know what
let's do it um
yeah um
our company is completely self-funded uh
using my partner owns fifty percent i
own fifty percent um i in our some
employees own a little bit so it's a bit
less than 50 50 but
um yeah
the company is doing well um we're
growing um
yeah we
we have crazy plans so it's
it it really it doesn't take any
anyone around the world could actually
do it it's uh obviously it helps if you
know how to code otherwise you need
someone who can code and you need to do
marketing
yeah
so it's pretty it's pretty much like
everything else anyone can do it but
you're the one doing it
i 100 i mean to me it's just like uh i
don't know facebook i mean
it's nothing special about facebook it's
just that zuckerberg was the one who
executed really well and then now at the
moment he's not executing so well um i
think it's really
it's all about execution actually i mean
ideas are are not that ideas are not
don't have that much worse uh execution
is everything
yeah
yeah there are many ideas
uh but for example it's the same if i
ask you like what is the difference
between you and the hundreds of chess
channels out there what is the
difference
it's execution
yeah yeah i don't i don't remove my
mistakes
it's execution i tell you it's it's it's
the consistency that that you make a
video literally or two or three videos
every single day that that you show up
um it i mean the games are the same i
mean people could just follow watch your
channel and then be like oh he's
analyzing this game let me also analyze
it right they could do this but it's all
about the execution that's what it
really comes down to
yeah not
not just
the the the choosing of the games
yeah and uh i wanted to ask you like you
have this now feature uh on um
on your website this new freezer thing
uh
where you can lock up like all of the
funds for like the uh 10 year period
uh what what do you expect like in 10
years from that
i mean this is we are just offering a a
blockchain so none of the services that
are offered on cake are actually offered
by k or created by cake yeah okay all
services together right so the
blockchain itself uh has this idea of
locking up a lot of funds and uh they're
by you get double their rewards from the
blockchain um and we passed this on to
our customers
um what do i expect i'm also freezing uh
some of my funds for 10 years um the
reason i do it is because i believe the
blockchain is going to do well and the
price is going to do well i i get double
the rewards it's double the cash flow i
i'm happy about that um and i think
the the price is going to do well over
10 years
and is the is the is the
uh
is your native coin the dfi is it uh
infinite or or i don't know what's the
word for it is it
notice it is kept at 1.2 billion and i
think right now there are 700 000 or
something in circulation so in about
nine years there the cap is going to be
reached there's no more new coins
uh-huh and it's only distributed by by
staking or
yeah by staking and by liquidity mining
um
all the various blockchain services that
are out there um but uh liquidity
staking generates uh a lot of the coins
yeah
so that's uh the estimate like in in
nine years it will be depleted
so basically uh if you go to d5 chain
hyphen analytics.com there uh there's a
community member who programmed that
entire dashboard and he calculates it
down to the very last uh block and
second when the last kind of coin should
be created
i think it's about nine years
so basically by the time the the the
freezing uh
correct stops uh okay okay yeah correct
correct so that's when the when the coin
really comes into fruition
i mean that's when there should be a
massive shortage because uh yeah no more
new coins are being created correct
what what is uh what is the purpose of
the of the dfi coin does it have one
yeah it does it a very strong purpose um
and you will see that actually this
quarter it's going to be very strong
it's uh used to create other assets so
it's used to create stocks and gold and
silver and and and precious metals and
so it basically fuels this entire
blockchain that creates all this uh yeah
decentralized tokenization um it's
it's it's built on top of bitcoin uh it
has the same code base so it's uh yeah
it's a very very very strong use case it
just took now about one and a half years
to completely uh get executed uh but
this quarter i'm
yeah i'm very very hopeful actually this
quarter about what uh d5 chain uh could
do um i think it's gonna be quite
interesting
all right i've i've read your article
you wrote some article on i don't know
the
uh it's uh maybe a medium or something i
don't know do you have articles on
medium
i have uh yes um
as well um some some are written by the
team some are written by by myself so it
depends um we do have a blog on medium
yeah
yeah i know i've uh you've answered
someone in the chat no in the in the
twitter
uh messages i think someone asked you
about something in the uh about your
previous theme
and you've explained it in that article
so do you still
there was a previous company i was
kicked out in that company and then
there were a lot of uh false allegations
swirling around and then i made this uh
article i think we
we created about a year ago and i
reposted it um just to kind of get rid
of these allegations um that uh people
thought that i was the one who closed
down the company and i wasn't then i
just wanted to do straighten this out
and explain this to people um that
actually it was my ex-partners who were
the one who were running off taking the
money and closing everything down
and yeah and so when someone asks me
about this i just post that article um
those people that want to read it they
can and those that don't they don't
do you still don't know why why they
kicked you out
no i mean i don't know
like for a fact but my assumption is
that they kicked me out because they
were super jealous uh they were jealous
of because of money um i think that is
always a big big reason um
and i just i i think they thought they
could run the company themselves and i
thought that they thought they had
everything um that they had the money
they had the banking license they had
the cards live and then at the end uh
they thought hey you know what we can do
it and uh they couldn't and then they
said you know what uh let's close the
company down uh disappear they took the
money disappeared
yeah
uh who needs who needs public relations
huh
that was a crazy story
and it took you how long uh for from
that point to
to start up with with cake defy
um i got kicked out uh begin uh 7th of
january 2019 and we started cake in june
so about six months uh it took it took
quite some time to
to like settle
um hewson was the main engineer in my
past company and uh
he was a like a lead blockchain engineer
uh we partnered up and yeah and look
crazy thing is uh
my ex partners they had so much money
that everything uh they completely
disappeared ran out ran away with the
money and at the same time we built up a
uh really fantastic companies actually
i'm uh i don't know uh looking back it
could have gone any better
yeah
all right uh
and uh
uh so far you're you're satisfied with
how it's going i mean it's uh still a
fairly young company
ah uh we couldn't uh
really we couldn't be any happier um
we're undergoing a uh like a large audit
in the us at the moment
where
everything in the business gets audited
and checked so let's see um let's see
what uh comes next after that um
the team is growing we're uh oh we're
doing well can't complain um
busy it's really really busy some people
on youtube always say i look so tired um
if i'm sick or something no i just work
a lot at the moment uh maybe i'll spit
with the jet lag
between europe and asia but uh yeah
and is uh is it ever is everything like
regulated from your country or do you
have it set up somewhere somewhere else
no uh singapore has uh so-called payment
services act that's like a regulation
framework and uh cake is part of that
entire framework um yeah so we have to
uh adhere to whatever the local
regulator set out uh they're relatively
strict um like they just shut down
finance and and uh yeah they're really
strict
they really take a lot of care so yeah
and how how long does it take for
example in in singapore from the moment
you
uh you know uh get the idea to to make
everything work uh you know
from a legal standpoint
ah that's so fast uh singapore is so
entrepreneur friendly it's crazy
yeah ah it's so quick
okay if you want to work go work
yeah they're really really fast uh
they're really open for
for entrepreneurs um i mean that was the
reason why we stayed in singapore and
and why we did it here um
yeah i think you cannot compare this to
the
to all the hurdles that some european
countries uh especially european
countries throw at you uh there's very
little uh issues on that so yeah
and how long have you been in singapore
it's my sixth year now uh yeah i came in
came to singapore in 2016.
so
yeah
but originally up and downsides it's
yeah
original you are from from germany
uh austrian uh i'm in germany right now
um because there's this special travel
arrangement between uh germany and
singapore so i'm not allowed to leave uh
germany um yeah and so yeah came here
invited the family and
uh which is crazy the family is allowed
to come in but we're not allowed to
leave but so what uh gotta stick to
wolves and uh yeah so
are there any any severe covet
regulations uh in singapore um and then
a complete lockdown at the moment oh
complete but like an almost locked down
uh it's uh at the moment they're really
really uh strict uh
yeah so it was a good time to be for a
few days here
but you you're allowed to return
yeah yeah there the the border is is
open but i mean i i wouldn't uh like
from germany that's fine uh but from
other countries they have different
regulations
um
do you have like uh like a favorite
chess game of yours
i haven't played uh enough that i have
like this one famous or one uh
favorite chess game
um
no i i don't i really don't i i haven't
played enough definitely not no no i
don't mean by yourself i mean by other
players
oh by other players um
[Music]
there was this uh i can't remember i
think it was um
magnus playing against fiorusa it was
like a bullet game um and he played this
really interesting opening where
um and you'd analyze this where like he
had prepared this so well and then like
i think he had it prepared for 20 moves
down and he just completely overwhelmed
uh uh fri ruta i i um i can't remember
the exact game it's
maybe played like a year ago or
something and and i was just so
impressed in um
well how
how
well someone would have had to have all
the decision trees kind of laid out in
such a short time because i think it was
like like a bullet format i was like
unfreaking believable that you remember
first of all all these things and you
have to be so insanely quick in oh he's
moving this i need to move this and i
was just so impressed with that um
i mean obviously there's so many
traditional games that are like popular
and so famous but that was to me that
was just so mind-boggling to see at what
speed he had memorized all these things
and he could just execute and i was like
wow it's like really like a machine and
and i that was just impressive to see
was it i don't know uh
from what you're saying is maybe the the
one where
uh magnus uh played the scandinavian
with black and ferruja sacrificed that
knight on b5 that magnus first declined
then he accepted it uh but yes that was
the game yes you're right correct
it was that interesting
yeah i think i checked him on on e6 or
something like that
yep
yeah that's uh that's a pretty wild one
uh i remember because the the night
sacrifice was correct magnus refused the
the sacrifice but then at the moment
when he accepted it then it was proper
properly accepted uh but still it uh you
know uh it was a
fine game for from both sides but uh
it's so much so much more difficult to
play it with black obviously
and also yeah it's bullet i mean
anything can happen and what's happening
here wow
ah the the the the two seconds that's
why white didn't go for that
yeah it's a it's a flag off
vitic uh wins
oh i actually played against
wow i i have a win against him that's he
probably got disconnected or something
all right so let me just check we have
40 minutes left in the tournament the
leader currently assenio uh he often
joins the the tournaments uh oh penguin
also joined in really oh let's check
this out i think this is penguin
yeah that's penguin
definitely 3 000 bullet rating
all right let's
let's see
uh he he often joins the tournaments
late and then he just wins but here it's
really everyone
yeah yeah
so we'll see okay he's uh
he just blundered his queen i believe or
no
no it was it was a deliberate uh
sacrifice
wow yeah he resigns that was that was
not a good game for him
what happened here
uh
he he got obliterated
by by the leader
oh vtick is also streaming very nice
oh yeah those are those are nice games
you get a
do you know most of the players um like
even like defeated masters and
international masters
uh some some i know by their handles but
if they don't have like their name in
the uh
in the
uh
sort of their pro alicia's profile then
of course no there are far too many of
them
grandmasters yes but uh international
masters and the video masters know there
are far far too many
and some some don't even apply for this
you have to like send a
a click
that you would like to be listed as a as
a rated player and then leech just you
know confirms it and then you get to
this yellow fm
but
some people i guess don't even do it
okay because they just don't care
yeah
there are some people i know in croatia
in croatia when you get like the
feeder master title you have to then pay
when you you want or no no you have the
national master and then when you want
to get defeated master which is like 50
rating difference you have to pay for it
and then some people you know don't get
it because
they just have to pay for it and they
don't really get anything for it
like it's not like you're going to get
invited to you know more tournaments or
anything okay if it's for if it was for
the international master title okay but
for the
uh for this one
they just don't
all right
cake uh i like the i like to start a
game that's only starting out so let's
try uh
okay penguin did really well that was
actually his first loss
yeah he has been
on a streak here
yeah he's always on a streak
uh is there a fair play review after the
tournament someone is asking yes of
course all the games are reviewed
constantly by by
the you know anti-anti-cheating software
and uh most of the players in the top
are very well known so
uh but yeah also the the engine is too
powerful yeah
i know i think uh anyone everyone can
join yeah
everyone can still join in uh chances
are you you might not win the tournament
as it's already uh lasting for for an
hour but uh you you can definitely join
no i do not think a senior is magnus
though arsenio's been
has joined many tournaments we've
organized so far and i i doubt it's
magnus
yeah sorry about not reading the
comments uh
all the time it's very rare that i have
a guest on the channel you're like my
second guest on the channel altogether
really who was the first one
uh rajabov
yeah he he joined in once but like for
for for like uh uh leeches tournament
stream
uh and i've had some guests in person
you know who who come over here
obviously then we stream together but
like uh you know a distance call guest
yeah i think pretty sure the second one
but i could be wrong
uh rob says your sister man yeah my
sister was in the stream with me but not
uh not via a call
yeah and now it it works uh it works
nicely last time i tried it i i couldn't
get the
uh the zoom call video to
you know properly fit into my obs
stream what uh and how do you get the
sound from from zoom um you just
basically use computer sound and that's
what you basically send over by obs yeah
that's why this is one rare occasion
where i actually use headphones so you
know people would again hear you twice
over my speakers and over you know just
computer audio
got it
yeah although it's if you ever try
playing bullet and streaming uh like
without sound it's incredibly difficult
like
just hearing the sound really makes
makes you play faster it's not like you
don't stress you out
no and you know a light travels faster
than sound but it's like when you hear
the sound that's when you you register
the move
like it's you know crazy but it it it
really feels like that
at least for me yeah sometimes i on my
crypto channel i do like chess video i i
stream playing chess
man and i just don't understand how
people can play chess and talk so much
at the same time i literally fall into
this deep trance and like i need to
think and then like suddenly people are
like hey can you talk something i like
it's this mute or what like yeah i can't
play and talk so much at the same time
have you ever streamed chess on your
channel yeah i have a couple of times
oh really not just
not just test streams
no no i actually like i don't know a
couple of like i don't know maybe six or
seven uh like two hour sessions um
yeah where i either get defeated because
obviously then uh in germany a lot of
people know me and then they're like oh
julian is playing okay let me beat him
and then they challenge me and obviously
then uh all the people that like they
create a new account 1500 and they just
wipe me out because they're actually
really really strong and and yeah so
yeah and they laugh at you of course
yeah that's uh
that's that's the highlight of the day
that to beat me so uh fine
yeah someone is asking is cake d5 the
same as paying pancake swap
no a very interesting uh
pancake swap started a year after us but
they became so popular because they had
this coin and uh it wasn't binding and
smart chain then they did so well so um
they are not uh we're not cake defy and
cake cake the coin is not our coin
really pancake is one year after cake d5
yep
uh they started afterwards um and uh
about a year um yeah because their coin
and because on being on binance smart
chain it just became so popular they
just exploded they basically became the
largest coin on top of
um on top of bsc uh because they forked
um yeah uh uni swap and sushi swap
all right so so there you have it not
not the same
uh right on
all right let me just check didn't see
the where's the chat is that on
youtube or because i only have the
leeches chat open there's not so much
oh no no no do you have the youtube chat
on the on the stream on the actual
stream
ah
got it got it got it let me see this
okay now i have the youtube chat i only
had the lead chest chest and there was
not so much action so
so what was your special or
i don't know how you said in medicine
your your special traumatology
pharmacology yep uh
accident er so that's great for for
being in crypto there's always trauma
always chaos
yeah so you can offer even medical
services
i i wouldn't i wouldn't trust myself
today anymore on any kind of medical
stuff it's man it's like 10 years ago
since last time that i had a white coat
on so yeah i wouldn't trust myself too
much
and
did you do the kite flying during the
the being a doctor part
not during being a doctor part but while
i was studying so i did a lot i mean a
lot i was like
yeah it was crazy times i was obviously
in my 20s and i was paid by companies to
travel all around the world be at the
most beautiful beaches that was a great
time um
is that like a popular sport in austria
yeah it's uh it's an okay sport all
around the world
yeah
yeah
i i have this um
ah what is the island called in croatia
which one
ah where the golden horn is what is this
thing called
golden horn
horn ah come on wait i'll figure it i'll
find it
um
red bull
okay okay okay
yeah i've been there i've actually
played chess there
uh what is the island
yeah
yeah and uh and uh yeah i that was a
barrage a lot of people posted in there
of course thanks uh posting it in there
yeah i uh i went uh kite surfing there
uh here i don't know if i can post
pictures into the chat um
maybe not i don't know i cannot post
links uh
uh in the
i don't think i can find it no no i i
don't think it's possible
yeah
uh it doesn't matter
yeah meadow is busy editing the next
video yeah
all right nice
all right so let me see is penguin
catching up to the leaders so he's
currently in seventh place and as usual
he joins the tournament very late and
then he tries to berserk everyone
uh to win the tournament but
i don't know but he's very close
actually if he he manages to get on one
another streak like this one
uh he could he could actually do it
yeah uh how much is left
how much time
30 minutes yeah to be really he has to
be pumping
yeah sometimes when he's late uh uh to a
tournament he
uh starts playing in the bus as he takes
a bus to school and then when he goes
home from school he starts playing on
his phone and then he continues
on his pc
so that's why some of his earlier games
might
you know
include a
blunder or two extra but then he gets
home where it's comfortable and then you
know he just obliterates everyone but
this is a fairly strong tournament
so we'll we'll see
all right let's see whenever we watch
his game he like uh
does something
yeah but i think he's he's fine here
yeah he's up upon but i don't think it
really matters in here
uh can you comment on why bitcoin is not
a ponzi scheme
um okay in a ponzi scheme there is
absolutely no utility in your investment
um but in bitcoin there's utility now we
can argue on how strong that utility is
of having something that's digital and
that is censorship resistant so
something that cannot be taken away and
it cannot be stopped from being sent
we can discuss how much value there is
in something like that i would say the
value is definitely not zero maybe it's
not what the value is right what the
price is right now or the price right
now is 60 something thousand for
uh one bitcoin maybe that's not the
price maybe the price is only ten
dollars who knows but i think um we can
all agree that there's some value in
having something that's digital that
cannot be stopped from sending that
cannot be taken away from you um and
as soon as there's this kind of utility
in there it cannot be a ponzi scheme
because a ponzi scheme doesn't have any
inherent value uh any inherent utility
and so calling bitcoin a ponzi scheme is
more or less being an ignorant actually
in understanding you know what a ponzi
scheme is or understanding what bitcoin
is the the argument that you have to
make is that this utility of being a
digital censorship resistance something
this utility is super tiny and therefore
it's totally overpriced i think that is
a very difficult point for bitcoin fans
to argue against i would agree with you
on that um but saying that the bitcoin
value is zero i think that's
i i think that's an ignorant argument to
be honest because it means you are
saying that there's no utility in that
and i would strongly disagree and i
think if you're honest you would also
disagree um
yeah i think the only question we need
to ask is it okay to pay a trillion
dollars for this network or not i
obviously think it is fine but uh
someone that says they don't think so
they can make a fair point
where do you yourself see bitcoin in
like 10 years
do you think about that i wrote a book i
wrote a book called cryptocurrency
simply explained i wrote that book in
2016. it's the only book that elon musk
was ever seen with like the only book
elon musk was ever seen with um i wrote
it that early and so maybe that was the
the lucky coincidence um in that book i
made the prediction that in 2025 uh we
would see about half a million dollars
in the bitcoin price so that's four more
years i think it's realistic to go there
um is it a guarantee no of course not
but i think there's a chance
um
yeah so i i still stand with that
prediction i made uh five years ago
to five hundred thousand dollars
yep yeah i think it's uh hey it's a
reasonable
um it's it's a reasonable guess um would
i say that that's a promise then no of
course not there's still an uh there's a
lot of risks in in bitcoin today i mean
uh like i think an interesting point
that many many
crypto
um haters should make right and that
what they're not making is because they
don't understand it well enough but like
a couple of things and i always think
you need to be able to to uh argue the
other side right so let's argue the
bitcoin critics side um one big argument
i would make as a bitcoin critic is that
no one knows who satoshi is so no one
knows who is the founder uh the the
creator and that's actually a huge risk
because satoshi has between five to ten
percent of all the bitcoins so if he
were to actually be malicious and no one
knows who it is um he could start
dumping and he would totally crash the
price so any bitcoin fan any anyone who
says bitcoin can never like go to zero
you're wrong um
he bitcoin you don't know who satoshi is
so by definition that is a risk that's
not calculable and i think a lot of
bitcoin fans don't understand that at
all um i think that's a big one the
other one is tether it's this uh central
kind of bank that's in the crypto space
um has 69 billion dollars and no one
knows if that money actually exists i
think it's a huge risk and i think these
are really valid arguments to make that
uh an investment in bitcoin could
totally be disastrous i think that's a
really really important point and i
think a very few
uh people who understand that market
actually understand what's going on
so what's your take on this is is
satoshi someone who just wanted to give
the world something better or is is he
just waiting for the right moment to
sell
uh i i think he's benevolent i i don't
think he's malicious
um
but i always have this little bit of a
skepsis so which would always keep me
from overexposing myself into that
entire ecosystem
[Music]
and and by definition no one knows right
so by definition no one is able to
calculate that risk so anyone that says
the fbi is satoshi is
their belief is just as much correct as
someone says no it's actually a super
like benevolent uh
uh person that's like a cryptographer
that just wanted to help the world both
are completely correct because we don't
know
yeah
so it was like
him and zodiac now now it's only him
it's actually bill gates yeah
yeah i doubt that
all right
uh let me just check this one
satoshi was a woman the whole time
yeah i mean
but no one ever claimed it was a man
right
ah
i still believe that uh satoshi is a
group um yeah i i believe it's a group
of people i think that is a super likely
scenario and probably a few members of
this group are dead or don't have access
there's this really crazy uh
i don't want to say conspiracy theory
there's this really crazy theory about
this uh criminal i can't remember his
name someone in the chat definitely
knows maybe you can post it who's
actually in prison and he got locked up
like literally right at that time when
satoshi disappeared from uh the bitcoin
forum and stopped posting there and yeah
man there are like a lot a lot of really
weird crazy conspiracy theories around
that so um
yeah
it could be right and so if that person
ever gets out um and that would also
explain why
these coins never sold
so if that person ever gets out
uh yeah paulie rue exactly uh ananta
here posted um yeah it's the is the
right person but i mean
he could easily sell them from prison i
mean it's not like he doesn't have
visitations or no i mean maybe he
doesn't have access to the private keys
right so he needs to have access to the
private keys and if he was any kind of a
pro he would have put those private keys
somewhere um definitely not with him and
so he needs to get access to them
because he doesn't have the private keys
so as soon as he has them he could sell
but i mean that's these are crazy kind
of
uh conspiracy theories out there but
wouldn't satoshi being the the the
master that he is just remember his
private keys like when he know them by
heart
i don't know i highly doubt so because
these are i mean back then um you didn't
have any kind of good system so these
were randomly generated numbers um
i i i don't know i mean look i don't
want to talk for someone how smart
someone can be but i think it's very
unlikely that someone remembers like
hundreds of
uh 20 uh 128 digits
uh numbers i think that's just
i mean nonsense it's possible i would
just say it's unlikely uh it's
improbable uh-huh in those days there
wasn't like a 12-word key or something
no that came way later that was in 2011
i think uh with uh with the bitcoin
improvement proposal in 2011 uh you
didn't have uh seats back then you
really had to have the raw private key
and why is this person in prison
oh man uh he's uh like
you need to read i think it's a
bloomberg article that was like or a new
york times article i can't remember um
insanely well researched on what this
person was doing i mean he was doing
like literally anything like from money
laundering ordering murders uh drug
dealings anything that's like insanely
crazy and so
there's some really weird uh
ideas here what's possible uh again i i
don't think he is satoshi i really don't
think so but it's a very
interesting kind of coincidence maybe on
when did you have to go to prison and uh
and when did uh some when did satoshi
stop posting on the forum so there are
there are possibilities there it's it's
a crazy really like i think what makes
bitcoin so
so interesting right and is is that
there's so much uh
yeah mystery around certain things and
and speculation and obviously conspiracy
theories and and at the end that's what
makes the legend live
if if bitcoin was just another startup
with a known ceo i there's no way it
would have accomplished what it has
yeah
yeah
yeah but uh as as far as i know uh
satoshi hasn't really written anything
or or you know contacted anyone for a
long long time now
yeah zero and and and there was no
conclusive proof by anyone
um that was ever made that uh showed
that he or she or they
may or may not be satoshi so um
yeah i mean my like what is the most
likely scenario at least in my head um
maybe hal finney was part of it um
yeah
maybe clyman there was this entire kind
of uh like story with with iron climb
and
these are all like ideas that could be
part of a group um and
and and maybe some people had certain
parts of the key
these are like some possible stories but
uh
i don't think yeah i don't know i think
that's possible um to me the most likely
scenario
yeah uh do you know is bitcoin the first
attempt at something like this or is it
just the one that uh you know became
popular
no um it it's had one interesting
um
like that before like nick sabo uh was
actually i mean he was someone who
actually with big gold um laid actually
the foundation for a lot of things and
um also um
um
it's super late already i've had a
really long day um
uh it doesn't matter uh whoever that was
there were a lot of attempts that the
huge difference between
anything else and bitcoin um for it
was this concept of getting of how to
get a voting right and the voting right
basically came from proving that you did
work and so it was all about
gaining voting rights on the next block
based on mining proving your work and
that was the breakthrough that was the
breakthrough that no one had thought of
before to to attach that part to a
currency and um and also not to give
like more incentive for more voting
rights but actually keep the incentive
of 50 blocks for example exactly the
same and red
adjust the time frame and so that was
super super innovative and and these
were ideas that no one understood before
um or or had thought of before and and
that's at the end what made bitcoin
um survive um yeah because it yeah
that's that was strong yeah
but now as i understand that proof of
work is sort of like uh you know last
year's technology
yeah i i mean i don't know i think i'm
not sure if uh if if that is something
i don't know i i i'm not sure if if it's
all about tech right if it or if it's
really more about a network i think
that's actually a key question
uh-huh
do you have any other uh obviously you
yourself are are very much in bitcoin do
you have any other coins that are
interesting to you
uh i have three positions um these are
my main
uh positions bitcoin is my largest my
second one is d5 chain and my third one
is ethereum i'm not much of a
speculative investor when it comes to
crypto um
i invest just like you say i invest long
term i've been in space for super long
time i've seen the ups the downs the
highest lows
like in chess you only you only invest
as well
you only root for magnus in chess yeah
yeah
again and i bet on bitcoin i bet on
ethereum so you know
yeah i
uh
i i think there's some romance for a lot
of people to bet on the underdog right
and and obviously the david and goliath
story is always super nice but
i don't know um
i just think uh it's way more profitable
to bet on the winners uh rather than
hoping that uh some outsiders is going
to win so
uh that's at least my approach but look
anyone should do with their money what
they think is the right thing
to do with my money what i think is the
right thing so
so you so you
you try to to give a little bit back to
chess for some reason yeah
man i've been like look uh i like the
reason why cake made a donation to your
channel why we're doing this like i i
want to be really clear like uh like at
no point did i
did i ask that uh um i i don't know i i
want to be on your channel when when i
gave you that donation i i told you that
straight away i said look i don't want
anything in return um i just want to
support your channel i think what you're
doing is really awesome i love watching
your videos
uh no no i mean i'm i need to switch off
so yeah no i'm the one that invited you
yeah
yeah and and also like today right and
and for me like i'm super happy to to
give that price of three thousand
dollars in total we talked about like
let's organize something really huge for
christmas or something right i'm
super open to that i i just
i don't know i i feel
like the crypto space has been super
generous to me i just is a hobby uh
crypto's business um
i don't know uh
i
i just love playing chess i'm not a i'm
not an excellent chess player and i just
want to support the space um
yeah if we can do and if we can help i
think it's always good and i think
that's needed as well um
yeah
yeah a nice a nice pre-christmas
tournament that would be that would be
definitely something that that everyone
would enjoy
because every that time is like super
packed with uh action all across the
board we have the world chess
championship in november then in
december world uh
blitz championship world rapid
championship and then you know
there's just so much chess there that
it's it's really really
uh insane but it makes sense because
it's uh interesting for advertisers you
know there's uh
much more views better better pricing
better everything so
i i guess it's it's it's something that
just has to be done
uh but yeah very
very very interesting that
that you you're also interested in that
uh i think pretty much
a lot of people that have met in the
crypto space are into chess i don't know
for for what reason is that or maybe
it's just that most people are into
chess
do you know any other i think a lot of
the
no i think i know a lot of people that
are big into chess um in crypto and i
mean i i think i mean they're eating
either into poker or into chess i think
it's it's very rare that you see people
that are into both um and i just think i
mean jets obviously is a perfect
knowledge game um
it has this uh fascination of of
computation and i think crypto attracts
a lot of uh
um especially the early crypto people
they're very left brained very logical
very big thinkers very mathematical and
so chess i think is a is a huge
attraction um whenever we are at crypto
events i mean there's always people
playing chess um yeah it's uh i'm gonna
be on a on a crypto trip beginning of
january and there were already so many
people like ah i'm gonna bring a chess
board let's play we're gonna make a a a
crypto tournament yeah um
i think it's super interesting yeah i've
actually all the chess players i've met
in person pretty much the ones that i
hang out with and everything everyone
loves poker like not not a single chess
player almost i've met does not enjoy
poker
i don't know why but it's just you you
meet a lot a lot of uh people who are
really not like
they have a tendency for for one so like
when you ask someone who is like a good
poker player and you're like uh how much
do you play chess and you're like oh you
know i also like to play chess but
they're definitely better in one of
players
them
you you rarely meet someone who says oh
you know what like i also know how to
play poker and i i do play poker but if
you ask me which one do i know better
than chess even though i'm not that good
of a chess player um and i think it's
the same with poker players like you
have good poker players and yeah they
like to play chess but they're
definitely not the
super expert chess no no they're not
poker no no no
like i know daniel negrano for example
he he sometimes even streams chess and
he's quite often playing on chess.com
uh but yeah he is around maybe i don't
know
last time i checked i think he was
around 1200 uh but still
that's uh you know for for someone who
who's so so much into something else
that's that's not a little
yeah like this is an interesting
question from digital music are a lot of
chess players also into arts music
drawing it's a very right brain and i
actually don't think so i think uh
probably they for
chess players are probably into that i
don't know what's your take on that
uh well i can only consider chess
players that i know personally and
there's quite a lot of them and no
not many are into that no
like most are into you know what you can
you know do in in front of your computer
i mean obviously you can do art music
and everything in front of your computer
but
uh i i just don't know uh of of many
can you also comment on government bans
of cryptocurrencies seems reasonable
that governments protect the monopoly
and money um
it's almost impossible massoud for a
government to actually ban a a proper
decentralized cryptocurrency just like
bitcoin or ethereum um
but what governments will do they will
regulate all the platforms so they will
go to exchanges they will go to these
platforms and they will regularly dose
that's the way how to do it um
yeah but banning bitcoin is almost
impossible i wouldn't
like actually see a realistic way how to
do that but you can regulate so many
platforms and you see this you see
coinbase getting in issues uh basically
coinbase is like a bank now
that's how you how you actually regulate
it
but it's every time someone someone
tries to ban it or or anything it just
gets more popular and then you know
just more people get into it
yeah i mean you saw this uh about two
months ago when china kind of uh
totally banned bitcoin again for the
60th time yeah and you saw so much
chinese money uh exiting and going into
other countries
uh it's just super difficult to to block
something that's so decentralized and so
accessible yeah
but china now has its own uh native
cryptocurrency yeah oh look at this
checkpoint
it's like a stable coin eye it's like uh
it's a country regulated yeah
of course you're not gonna wake up one
day and be 10 times as rich
yeah
man how can you i'm sometimes surprised
i mean that's a 2300 player and then
sometimes i'm surprised how you don't
see that probably because of the the
time speed like the speed uh no it was a
it was a pre-move probably or yeah
but it happens i mean
it happens uh yeah sure i mean when you
look at it and you have some time then
it's fine yeah
uh
well it was kramnik uh world champion
vladimir kramny he missed mate in one uh
in his game against fritz the computer
and i believe that was a classical game
yeah that was a classical game
and it happened uh
on many other occasions between
no no time pressure classical game like
infinite time
yeah but you just get the end like don't
like normally even in classical at the
end there's quite some pressure no no no
it wasn't about time pressure and
there are many other occasions where it
just happens you know
it's uh no one no one yet has the the
correct term to describe this behavior
uh it's just uh
you know complete complete and utter
blindness uh you you you just uh i don't
know karpov once said that he thought he
already made one move and then this was
the second one that he wanted to play
and then he played this one
without actually playing the first move
so uh could be anything
it could be lack of sleep obviously it
would be a lot of things
all right so cake cake in space leading
the the cake defy arena
that's uh cool that's great
that's not someone you hired to play no
no
i don't know who that is
okay
but is
okay but penguin is uh in fourth and
he's on a really hot roll he is uh 96
points again you really think he can
catch up 12 points in seven minutes
that's like insane
if anyone can it's better and he's
playing against him
uh well uh
and that's andrew tang i don't know if
you if you know of him but uh like he's
in bullet he's like unstoppable but this
isn't bullet this is two plus so so his
opponents get a bit more time
and he uh berserks every game so he
gives away half of his time every every
time so if he wins he gets more
so it's like you know
he's he's he's investing
uh which uh against the grand master is
no small feat by any means
yeah
look at him 38 seconds just
re-maneuvering that night he doesn't
care
oh what what what what is this
he's just now he's just
trolling
what is this
wow
dude now i mean
what's that he's
now now he's he's he resigns now okay it
was a it was a good run but
cake in space
put a stop to it
all right so let's
uh i don't think now now it's not very
realistic that he he wins
i but it's you know he came in late he
berserks every game so
someone uh gave you money and said uh i
have an army of commenters i i really
don't
uh
that are as terrible or worse than me
really
man i don't know i really didn't do
anything bad uh
i think you either confusing me uh with
someone or i don't know uh
i don't know
what do you mean uh glad that i gave i
got money uh it's really for the chess
uh idea so
yeah
but uh i don't know if you've ever uh
are you on on reddit at all
no uh i have a reddit account but i
never deal with much with reddit no well
there's uh when i started youtube there
was so so much bad stuff written about
me on reddit it was like like you'd need
the days to go through it all
like it was uh it was uh unreal
so much so much uh negative stuff but uh
you know if you take that into
consideration
crypto also has that um
yeah
yeah it's still not uh yeah i saw it
because it was highlighted i guess
because that person gave i don't even
know i think that's uh indian rupee
yeah gave you 2 000 indian rupees so
that's why it was highlighted so that's
why i read it
yeah
but it's uh you know
whatever you're doing you're gonna
you're gonna have haters that's uh
impossible to avoid the more the more
followers you have the more the more
haters come with come with that
another one between cake and space and
and penguin
let's see
red is for potsers uh yeah i actually
have uh
i actually have a banned account on
reddit on the chess section uh because a
long long time ago like
when i before i even started the channel
i spammed so much with with some
uh chess stuff that i did you know they
just banned me and it's still banned so
uh unfortunately i cannot uh
join in on anything happening there
oh look skywalker has worse
i've ever heard of sorry what did you
want to say
no okay okay you have yours it's a much
shorter answer than then i believe this
one
luke skywalker asked
yeah i can answer both uh the worst in
my opinion was when um
uh parody the wallet uh there was an
attack uh to their smart contract and
they locked back then this was 2017 they
locked half a billion dollars uh so now
uh at current prices this must be like
billions of dollars so there's billions
billions of dollars are locked uh
up because they had this bug in their
smart contract
insane i think that's insane
uh the future of ethereum 2.0 um if they
ever manage to get the merger
which i hope they do then i think it
could be super positive so yeah that's
like planned for like next year
somewhere
like summer or something yeah that would
be that would be a
optimistic rate yeah so
when they first talked about it it was
planned for 2021 as i recall
uh that would be the goal yeah
yeah but
obviously not not happening
yeah
i i hope it does
um that would be great uh really um it
just these things get delayed and
delayed and late and late and
yeah
uh well
i think
but what has to happen for it to go
through i mean
like they just have to be i mean there's
just so many ethereum is really like
it's such a complicated and complex
system
and for them to kind of clean this up
and and reassemble everything
really it's like you have a car and
you're trying to get a uh
a a gas-powered car into an electric car
and you have to do it during the race
like you can't just stop and do it now
you have to do it during the race you
have to change every part and every
piece and you have to change the engine
and you have to do this during the race
really that's like how it is and and i
you just have to be so sure that this
works because if this screws up we're
talking about hundreds of billions of
dollars at risk and
yeah
uh so how do you make sure it works
without actually turning it on
yeah that's they testing they have test
nets and they just did yeah it
that's i mean at the end
to me the the interesting thing about uh
software engineering is always and i see
this in our company as well uh you have
people who test for everything but then
you have customers and suddenly there's
like they do something totally different
this analogy is always imagine your
computer program is a bar and then
the first tester comes in and orders a
beer and the computer program says great
here's the beer and then the next tester
comes in and says oh i want a bottle of
wine and the computer program says oh
here's the wine and then next one says
oh i want a whiskey and it's a whiskey
and i'm like oh it looks great
everything seems to be working and you
open it to the customers the customer
comes in what's the first question the
customer asks where's the toilet and
poof the entire thing flows apart yeah
yeah that's why oh wow we have a winner
taking space wins
yeah wins the cake defy arena that's uh
what what what could you ask for more
but
i actually forgot do we know who it is
no we still don't know who it is but it
doesn't matter like it's not uh
it's not important for for players to be
identified in order to to win uh prizes
and i think everything was uh very
nicely done like nothing was uh fishy or
you know uh and we could be relatively
sure right i mean that uh
that no one of them cheated or something
uh you mentioned this up front
yeah yeah because i know
okay i don't know some of them but those
in the top uh
seven i know uh so that can definitely
be
uh i mean you can never be 100 sure of
anything but uh here i wouldn't even uh
you know think twice about it uh so okay
congratulations to everyone cake in
space wins
uh with a performance of 2892
and he berserk rated uh 37 of his games
followed by a senior who also joins in a
lot of the tournaments here uh or
almost exclusively a bullet player as
you as you see uh with a rating with a
win rate of 73 percent and a 27 berserk
rate and sicla uh i don't know who that
is but i will check maybe it says nope
also an anonymous gentleman or a general
woman
uh
with uh
60 win rate and 85 berserk rate uh
let me just check penguin here real
quickly
uh
can i check i don't know i don't think i
can i just wanted to check if he's 100
berserk rate but uh
yeah i'm pretty sure he is as all of his
games are berserk
uh so we're gonna uh contact the winners
uh after the stream and then we're gonna
uh take care of the prizes so thank you
thanks everyone for joining and uh just
uh you know as a tradition we're gonna
read out the the top 10 uh in fourth
place matthew g uh p4p uh penguin in
fifth place feeding master ronda in
sixth flag will yeah in seventh uh
makino in eight anonymous six one five
nine six in ninth and algorithm one two
three in ten place congratulations
everyone
uh the tournament uh featured uh
1844 players and it's uh well
very very very impressive to win it like
this i think the winner lost only
five games
that's absolutely insane yeah
all right so that's it for this guys uh
julian thank you for joining me uh in
this stream it was a it was a really
good talk you did most of the talking
but that was kind of kind of the plan
uh
i think uh people wanted definitely a
bit more uh chess as it seems i think uh
they want to have some comments on the
chess side yeah okay but we we we
we have so very few guests on the
channel that when we have guests i i
like to have the the guest talking
yeah all right uh so thank you so much
uh antonio was super nice uh thanks so
much chat uh yeah hey uh if you want
check obviously check out cakedefy.com
uh we have a special code especially for
chess if you want to it's called chess
50.
um i can post it into the chat if you
want i don't know if you want to link
that up you get 50
uh crypto
um
that's really uh only with that code
otherwise you don't so try it out you
can see it for yourself
yeah
all right man
[Music]
thanks and that's it guys uh thank you
all for for joining in and uh see you in
the next one as usual uh
will be uh another very nice miniature
uh hopefully uh see you soon guys
appreciate it